>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Welcome to the African
and Middle Eastern Division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb,
chief of the division.
And I'm really delighted
to see you all here today.
I'm also extremely happy
to welcome Kyrgyz Ambassador
Kadyr Toktogulov to the African
and Middle Eastern Division
of the Library of Congress.
He has been here several times
before, however today he is here
in an official capacity to
present a short documentary
on Chingiz Aitmatov, the
most important Kyrgyz author
of the 20th Century.
Ambassador Toktogulov
was the person
who originally introduced us to
today's speaker, Jeffrey Lilley.
But in fact we had met
earlier ten years ago
when we first had a major
conference on Chingiz Aitmatov.
And he was there and he
told me that he was there
and he had just started
writing his book
and today we're having Jeffrey
Lilly with a book completed
and ready to share
with everyone here
and across the world because,
as you know, we're being webcast
and therefore this
program is going
to appear around the world.
And the book with
the wonderful title,
"Have the Mountains Fallen?"
It's an intriguing title.
I want to hear more about it.
It will be on sale
after this program.
Now a few worlds about
Ambassador Kadyr Toktogulov --
On December 31,
2014 Kyrgyzstan's President
Almazbek Atambaev appointed him
as Ambassador Extraordinary
and Plenipotentiary
of the Kyrgyz Republic to
the United States of America.
And two months later
on February 23,
2015 he presented
his credentials
to President Barack
Obama and took office.
However that was not all.
The following year
on February 24,
2016 Kadyr Toktogulov
was again appointed
by President Almazbek Atambaev
as Ambassador Extraordinary
and Plenipotentiary
to Canada this time,
but as he could not
divide himself into two,
his residence is
officially in Washington D.C.
So he presented his credentials
to the Governor General
of Canada David Johnston
on March 22, 2016.
We're thus very honored
today to have
with us two Ambassadors
in one person.
So we are delighted
to welcome him here.
Prior to his appointment
as Ambassador,
Kadyr Toktogulov served
as President Atambaev's Press
Secretary having worked earlier
as the Chief of Information
Policy in the Office
of the Prime Minister
of Kyrgyzstan.
There he was in charge of
coordinating media relations
for the Prime Minister,
his deputies,
and key government officials.
He also coordinated
media coverage
of the work of the government.
Ambassador Kadyr Toktogulov
is also a very experienced
journalist, having
worked as a correspondent
for the Associated Press
between 2003 and 2006,
the Dow Jones Newswires, as well
has having contributed a number
of stories for the Wall Street
Journal between 2006 and 2011.
He holds a BA degree
in Journalism
and Mass Communications
from the American University
of Central Asia,
Bishkek, Kyrgyzstan,
and was an exchange student
at Ankara University, Ankara,
Turkey, 1998 and 1999 and also
at Ithaca College between 2001
and 2002, here in New York.
So in addition to
Kyrgyz he's fluent
in Russian, English,
and Turkish.
And now let us all
welcome the Ambassador
who will introduce
a film for today.
[ Applause ]
>> Kadyr Toktogulov:
Thank you very much
for this very generous
introduction Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb.
Dear friends it's wonderful
to see you all today
at the book launch of
the newly released book
by my friend Jeff Lilley.
We've spoken earlier
today to figure
out what year we actually met
in Kyrgyzstan and we figured
out it was 2005 in Bishkek.
Before I speak about
today's event and the book
and the author, Jeff Lilley,
I'd like to express
my deepest gratitude
to the Library of Congress.
It's a very special institution
that holds a unique importance
for the United States
and the world libraries.
Special thanks to the African
and Middle Eastern Division,
Chief of the Division
Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb
and Joan Weeks Head Near East
Section and Turkish Specialist.
Thank you very much for
hosting today's event.
My embassy colleagues and I
have enjoyed working with you
on putting together
this book presentation.
I especially enjoyed our
conversations about the vast --
I especially enjoyed
our conversations
about the vast collection
of Central Asian literature
that the Library holds.
And the best moments of our
discussions were talking
about my home country Kyrgyzstan
and our most famous writer
the late Chingiz Aitmatov.
I'm grateful to the Library
and to you Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb
and Joan Weeks for agreeing
to host the presentation
of this fascinating book,
"Have the Mountains?"
You told me you liked the title
of the book [laughs] back then
when we were discussing the
details of today's event
and I really like it too.
I was a journalist
when Jeff and I met.
He was working in Bishkek
as the Country Director
of the International Republican
Institute in Bishkek Office.
He recently returned
to Kyrgyzstan
to continue his support
for my country
and my country's
democratic development.
The book is really fascinating.
It's my country's journey to
independence through the stories
of its two outstanding
sons that had lived
through Kyrgyz nation's
tragedies
in the 20th Century before
the country declared its
independence in 1991.
I'm very happy that this
event is taking place
as we celebrate the
90th birthday
of our great writer
Chingiz Aitmatov.
His books and stories
put Kyrgyzstan on the map
for many people around the world
and helped my country stand
firmer in today's world.
I have personal stories about
the two heroes of the book
that I'd like to share with you.
Chingiz Aitmatov is
my favorite writer.
His books kept me
awake at nights
as I was reading his
stories about the lives
of his characters during
and after the Word
War II in Kyrgyzstan.
I was happy when I got
to see him in Ankara
at the conference
when I was a student.
I would manage to get an
autograph in a book by him
that I was reading at the time.
He was a great master in how
he told a story of my country
and people during difficult days
which tested human beings
courage, decency, kindness,
generosity, and love
for the country.
The importance of Chingiz
Aitmatov to the Kyrgyz Republic
and the Kyrgyz people
is significant.
Nobody has made a
stronger contribution
to today's Kyrgyzstan
self-identity than Aitmatov.
This year we're celebrating the
90th birth of our great writer
and we see this book launch
as part of the celebrations.
When I was here in
the U.S. 2001, 2002,
I attempted to meet
Azamat Altay.
I was very much fascinated
by his personal story
of his journey all the
way from Kyrgyzstan
to the U.S. though the horrors
of World War II and challenges
of his life in Europe.
Through some Kyrgyz contacts
I managed to get hold
of his home phone
number and dialed him.
As Azamat Altay picked up
the phone and I spoke to him
in Kyrgyz and told him
that I wanted to visit him,
he gave me his home address.
But back then there
were no smartphones
that would guide you though
a city that you don't know.
I couldn't get any tips on how
to get to Flushing Meadows.
I was in New York for
a couple of days only
so I failed to visit him.
And to be honest I regret not
having made the efforts back
then to see this great man.
Jeff, you did a great job in
telling the intertwining stories
of Chingiz Aitmatov
and Azamat Altay.
And through their stories you
told a story of my country.
You really took us through
the days of the Urkun,
the Great Tragedy and the
flight of the Kyrgyz people
to China during their
violent crack
down by the Soviet
Russian troops.
You took us through the tragic
years of the World War II.
And in your book you took us
through my country's
journey to independence.
It's an emotional book and it's
an important book if one wants
to learn about the
Kyrgyz Republic
and its best representatives.
Chingiz Aitmatov and
Azamat Altay are among them.
As Ambassador of an
independent Kyrgyzstan I'd
like to say thank
you for the book,
for your hard work writing this
book, and your respect and love
for my country, my
country's people and heroes.
Thank you, Jeff.
I really look forward to
the presentation and last
but not least I'd like to
thank Venera Djumataeva,
Director of Kyrgyz Service of
RFE/RL who came all the way
from Prague for this
event and also helped us
with the presentation by
making, producing this video
that we'll see that will
introduce the heroes of the book
that Jeff wrote before
his presentation.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
>> Two Kyrgyz men who whose
lives were adversely affected
and forever changed by
the biggest tragedies
of the 20th Century -- Chingiz
Aitmatov and Azamat Altay.
Two people whose lives
reflect all the political
and moral lessons
of the century.
Chingiz Aitmatov, the
most famous Kyrgyz writer,
lost his father to Stalin's
repressive regime in 1938
and only found where his
father had been executed
and buried 53 years
after it occurred.
Not only his father, a
promising young Kyrgyz leader,
but several of his
uncles also fell victim
to the soviet dictatorship.
Aitmatov hid his deep inner
sadness after losing his father
at the age of nine and dedicated
his life to educating himself
and his three younger siblings.
He became an internationally
known whose books,
which have been translated
into more
than 160 languages describe the
national character, lifestyle,
and existential philosophy
of the nomadic Kyrgyz people.
In every book Aitmatov
created a hero
who in whatever difficult
circumstances he
or she was forced
to live would choose
to live freely, happily,
and fully.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> The Kyrgyz author
was a supporter
of Soviet President Mikhail
Gorbachev and advised him
on the implementation of the
very first political reforms
in the final years of the USSR.
He was later appointed Soviet
Ambassador to Luxembourg
and then was Kyrgyzstan's
Ambassador
to the Benelux Countries
spending the last 18 years
of his life in Europe,
mostly Brussels.
Even after his death, Aitmatov's
books and their heroes continued
to introduce Kyrgyzstan as a
beautiful mountainous country
and its people rich character
and values to the entire world.
[ Music ]
Azamat Altay, a young and
educated Kyrgyz man decided
to stay in the west after
World War II after realizing
that he would be punished
in the USSR since serving
as a POW in a Nazi Camp.
That decision cut him off from
his homeland, from his father,
and other relatives
for 55 years.
Eager to make a connection
with his homeland,
Altay made contacts
with other Russian
and Soviet dissidents
living in Europe
and attended several
gatherings of Central Asian,
and Soviet dissident,
even writing articles
for dissident publications.
He was later appointed an editor
of the [inaudible]
magazine published
by Central Asian
dissidents in Europe.
Through those connections Azamat
Altay became radio for Europe,
Radio Liberties very
first Kyrgyz broadcaster
in March 1953.
It his work, Altay had to
cover many taboo topics
in Soviet Kyrgyzstan such as
victims of Stalin's repression,
young Kyrgyz writers,
intellectuals,
poets and politicians whose
names let alone their works were
forbidden in the Kyrgyz
media at the time.
Alta, and later his
new Kyrgyz colleagues
at RFE/RL covered issues
regarding the Kyrgyz diaspora
living in Afghanistan,
Turkey, and Pakistan.
RFE/RLs Kyrgyz service also
paid a lot of attention
in the early years to
Kyrgyz language, customs,
and history issues in the
ever increasingly Russified
Soviet Kyrgyzstan.
Azamat Altay collected some
6,000 books and magazines
on Kyrgyz and Central
Asian topics at his home
and had helped some
prominent western academics
to conduct their research
on Kyrgyzstan behind
the iron curtain.
He reported for RFE/RL Kyrgyz
service for some 40 years.
Attacked regularly by the
Soviet Kyrgyz media as a traitor
and enemy of the people,
Azamat Altay still had
his secret supporters
and admirers in Kyrgyzstan.
Intellectuals, writers,
and scholars would listen
to RFE/RL Kyrgyz programs
at their dachas often built
atop hills with better reception
and they would discuss
Altay himself
and RFE/RL Kyrgyz service
programs among themselves.
Some of the topics were related
to the Soviet Communist
Leadership
and political corruption issues.
That's why in 1995 when Altay,
a retired veteran journalist
and former RFE/RL Kyrgyz Service
Director was finally invited
to independent Kyrgyzstan and
arrived in the Capital Bishkek,
he was greeted as a national
hero as a Kyrgyz American
who had devoted his
life to the struggle
for his people's
freedom and independence.
For Kyrgyz language,
culture, and history.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Music ]
>> Chingiz Aitmatov and Azamat
Altay were born in Kyrgyzstan
but spend most of their lives
on two different
sides of the Cold War.
Yet they were still able to meet
several times during the Soviet
Era and again later in
independent Kyrgyzstan.
They had some important
common goals in life --
to find their lost fathers,
to fight for their
people's freedom,
to preserve their national
history, culture, and language
and to find justice and freedom
in ordinary people's lives.
[ Music ]
>> Joan Weeks: I turn
from an ovation person
into this introduction.
So on behalf of all my
colleagues in the African
and Middle Eastern Division I'd
like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone
on this very special
90th Birthday celebration
for Chingiz Aitmatov.
What a fantastic person.
I mean this movie just
gave us a little snapshot,
but I'm so pleased to be able to
work with Ambassador Toktogulov
and the Embassy of Kyrgyzstan.
And as head of the
Near East Section,
the sponsor of today's
program, we're very pleased
to present this program.
And we just are so
delighted that Jeffrey came in
and used the Library of Congress
collections for his research.
This is a fantastic division
that combines all of Africa.
We cover 78 countries and
more than two dozen languages
and we have all of these
specialists here that will hope
that you come and use
these wonderful collections
for your research as well.
We also invite you to cover
and use our social media.
We've got Facebook, we've got a
blog, and you can hear about all
of our other programs as well.
And just a slight note that
this whole program is being
videotaped for future broadcast,
so we welcome a couple
questions perhaps at the end,
but just to let you know
that you're giving permission
to be videotaped if you do.
And so I'd like to move right
on without any further ado
to an introduction
of Jeff Lilley.
He received his undergraduate
degree in history and Russian
from Williams College
and a master's degree
in Soviet Studies
from Johns Hopkins.
And do you realize it was the
last time they gave that degree
because Soviet Studies turned
into studies of about all
of the Central Asian Countries.
And he worked as a
journalist in Russia reporting
for the Far Eastern Economic
Review and Sports Illustrated
as well as Voice of America.
And after witnessing the
collapse of the Soviet Union
as a journalist in the 1990s,
he moved to Central Asia in 2004
where he began to work in the
field of international democracy
and governance in support of
transitions in the countries
of Eurasia in the Middle East.
And during a three-year period
as a posing in Kyrgyzstan
from 2004 to 2007, he
started reading the works
of Chingiz Aitmatov.
He slept in yurts, which I
think is a fabulous opportunity
to really get to
know the country.
He drank fermented mare's milk.
I'm not sure I'd do that.
He hiked in the country's
beautiful mountains.
And over the next ten years he
worked in the field of democracy
and governance support
in Washington D.C.
in the Middle East.
He continues his research and
finished his book as well.
In 2016 he returned
to Kyrgyzstan
to lead a British funded
parliamentary support program.
He's also the author of
"China Hands: Nine Decades
of Adventure, Espionage,
and Diplomacy."
And so without further ago I'd
like to welcome Jeff
Lilley to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Jeffrey Lilley: What a treat.
I think it's my turn
to say thank you
to the Library of Congress.
As Mary Jane has referred to
and Joan, I spent a good number
of hours in this Library
working with microfiche,
working with books, and doing
the research for this book,
which is a labor of love,
which as was mentioned took me
ten years to research and write.
The Library of Congress
is a treasure
and a direct manifestation
of American democracy.
Thank you to those
of you who work here
to make your incredible
buildings --
holdings, sorry organized, and
your building is organized,
and available to
writers like me.
This is definitely
a team effort.
I was here ten years ago when
the Library of Congress put
on a celebration
that was supposed
to mark Chingiz Aitmatov's
80th Birthday.
But instead it became a
celebration of his life
after he died in June 2008.
That was a great event with
speakers from around the world,
a speech by Dr. James
Billington,
a screening of the film
"Jamila" and a display
of Aitmatov's books in many
languages including Aramaic.
You could say the event
launched this book project,
which not comes to a close
right here full circle.
So onto the book, I'm
going to -- yeah --
so I know everybody here
knows where Kyrgyzstan is
and I know they know
exactly how it's spelled.
My father, who was a diplomat
was a little bit shaky
on how to pronounce it.
But anyway this is
a map of Kyrgyzstan.
And I'll just point out here
-- can you guys see my cursor?
Yeah, Sheker is where Chingiz
Aitmatov is born in the west.
And Kodjomberdiev, right here on
the beautiful Lake Issyk-Kul was
where Azamat Altay was born.
So these are two warriors for
freedom from Kyrgyzstan --
Chingiz Aitmatov
and Azamat Altay.
And it's a country as
was mentioned by Joan
that I first lived
in from 2004 to 2007.
Aitmatov was an intellectual
warrior
and Altay was a battle
hardened warrior literally
who carried the scars of
war with him through life.
Both were embolden by
their experiences to fight
with words -- one writing,
one speaking, the good fight.
So as was mentioned
I arrived in 2004
and I started reading
Aitmatov's body of work.
Short stories and novels written
over 40 years during my posting
and I finished a
couple of years later.
That was just the reading, when
working back in Washington D.C.
"Have the Mountains Fallen?"
is a story of the Cold War
from the other side with roots
in the 1920s and '30s
when Soviet power was
establishing itself
across the Eurasian landmass.
It tells the parallel
stories of Aitmatov and Altay,
two men who travel separately
though life until they meet
and find common cause, in of all
places New York City in 1975.
Their life stories
are testaments
to the human spirit's
quest for freedom.
Their lives are proof that
lives live only for so long.
That truth, as evidence by
the attainment of justice
and redemption is
achievable and that the search
for a meaningful life is
based on individual freedom.
So everybody is familiar
with Kyrgyzstan country,
descended from nomads, 90%
mountains, and home to some
of the most beautiful and
pristine nature in the world,
as you can see from
the cover of the book,
which is actually
my wife's photo.
My wife is a photographer
and she's here today.
And we thought we
could do better
than Indiana University Press,
which got a beautiful photo
but my wife's was better.
So let's move on.
Like so many other
citizens, this is a picture
of Torekul Aitmatov,
Chingiz Aitmatov's father
and a young Chingiz
when he was probably
about two years old in 1930.
Like so many other citizens
at that time, Azamat Altay
and Chingiz Aitmatov's
father pictured here,
believed in Soviet power
which had brought literacy,
electricity, hospitals and
schools to the Kyrgyz people.
They served it loyally until
Stalin's terror started
to wreak havoc across the
Soviet Union in the 1930s.
The purges swept up
Torekul Aitmatov in 1938.
Train station, there's a
vivid scene in the book
where Chingiz Aitmatov
says goodbye to his father
and not even knowing that
he'll never see him again
on the train station in Moscow.
Those purges made a
disbeliever out of Azamat Altay
and they shape Chingiz
Aitmatov's life.
World War II was a crucible for
both Altay and Chingiz Aitmatov.
They were eight years
separated, the men.
Altay was born in 1920.
Chingiz Aitmatov
was born in 1928.
So by the time World War II
happened in the Soviet Union,
they were both young men.
As a 14-year-old in a
village bereft of men
because they had all
been called to the front,
Chingiz Aitmatov
delivered death notices
to families whose fathers, sons,
or uncles had died in the war.
So I want to read you a little
passage from the book on that.
So Chingiz Aitmatov has just
delivered a death notice
to a family.
Chingiz would then stare at
the ground uncomfortable,
14 years old, shifting his feet.
Usually he would hear a
heavy sigh from the mother,
then whimpering or heaving,
and finally crying would rend
the air like a plate shattering.
Chingiz would stand there a
young boy with nowhere to run
and no way to console.
Villagers began associating
the young village assistant
with bad luck.
As soon as households
saw him riding
down the street they would
shun him like an evil spirit.
"Don't come to our house,"
they would say, "Pass by.
Don't bring us bad news."
Such a young boy shouldering
such heavy responsibilities
to suffer the village's grief
as the messenger of bad news,
a piece of paper in
exchange for a son.
But this was how Soviet Society
endured during World War II
or the Great Patriotic War
as it is known in Russian.
Ironies overwhelm, the
distant war reeking havoc
in an isolated village,
teenagers running village
affairs and a boy not big enough
to mount his horse
delivering death sentences --
not death sentences,
death notices.
Meanwhile Soviet conscript Altay
was scrambling for his life
after being overrun by the
German Blitzkrieg in June 1941.
He was serving in
Soviet occupied Lithuania
at that point.
Altay escaped from Nazi
POW camps not once,
not twice, but three times.
Eventually joining
French Freedom Fighters
on the march to liberate Paris.
He dreamed of returning to
his home village on Issyk-Kul,
you saw that, but Soviet
Leader Stalin's perverse logic
considered Soviet
POWs as traitors just
because they had the
misfortune to be captured alive.
That meant prison camp in
Siberia for someone like Altay,
even though he had
crisscrossed Europe fighting
for his own survival and
always opposing the Nazis.
It was absurd.
Altay ended up making a decision
which irrevocably
change his life.
After midnight on --
this is from the book --
After midnight on January
1st, 1946 Altay was serving
as a Soviet border guard then --
as revelers and cities
around Europe were raising
their glasses to the end
of World War II, Soviet border
guard Azamat Altay tossed aside
his rifle, threw off his
military overcoat and stole
across the boarder
into the English zone
of recently liberated Germany.
Altay headed south from the
English zone in Germany,
he was determined to get
to France, the only country
that had welcomed him
and where he had friends
from his partisan days.
Using a smattering
of French, German,
and Russian he begged a ticket
off an elderly station worker
at the Saarbrucken
Train Station.
Lacking permission to cross the
still-militarized German-French
border, he stowed away, hiding
in the first-class bathroom.
Altay arrived in Paris,
a free but penniless man,
with not a French
franc to his name.
A passerby gave him two
francs to ride on the subway.
It was a bumble start
to a new life,
but with each mile he traveled
on foot by train or subway --
he was leaving behind the
tragedies of the past.
In Europe after the war, Altay
scrambled to make a living.
He did manual labor in
small towns in France.
It was a lonely time with few
friends among the rural French
who had no idea where
he came from.
As a matter of fact there's
this little story in the book
about Altay was so
lonely that he got a dog
and he would put this dog in
a cart and then he would kind
of wheel the cart I guess around
the little village he was in
and he named the dog
"My Friend" in Kyrgyz,
which is "Menin Dosum".
And they called him --
the French villagers called
him "The Chinese with a dog."
That's the best they could get.
Altay eventually educated
himself anew, immersing himself
in European philosophy in
the struggle for independence
of Soviet Central Asia.
in 1953, as we saw in
that wonderful film,
he became the voice of Radio
Liberty broadcasting back
into Soviet Kyrgyzsia.
So it's two parallel stories.
So I'm going to be
jumping back and forth.
Meanwhile, Aitmatov, scarred by
the disappearance of his father,
here's Aitmatov as a
young man you can see.
I guess he's to his
mother's left.
And this is his brother Ilgez,
and this is his sister Roza
who is still alive and well.
And Ilgez and Roza are both
alive and well in Bishkek
in their 80s, and this is
his sister Luzia behind him.
So scarred by the disappearance
of his father in 1937,
Aitmatov was keeping his head
down and as the eldest male
in the family, nine years old,
trying to help his
family survive,
he was considered the son
of an enemy of the people,
denied his scholarship, refused
his stipend, and denied entrance
into graduate school
despite stellar grades.
He took to writing instead.
He wrote stories of independent
minded fallible people
who on the outside may have
been loyal Soviet citizens.
But reading between the lines
his heroes bucked the system.
Whether it was patriarchal
tradition,
Soviet ideology, or groupthink.
How Aitmatov did this under
Soviet censorship is one
of the most fascinating
parts of this story.
He contorted himself, hid
behind the Kyrgyz language,
which sensors didn't
understand, and compromised
where and when necessary.
As someone who knew
him well told me
when I was researching the book,
"When Chingiz Aitmatov got
behind a desk he couldn't lie."
So he starts to break into
fame and be famous., in 1963,
and his reputation
or his family's reputation
is resurrected
when he wins the Lenin
Prize of 1963 for a series
of short stories, one of which
was "Jamila", who I'm sure a lot
of people in this
room have read.
Beautiful story.
So here is a wonderful picture
of Chingiz Aitmatov selling
his books at a book fair.
And you can see "Jamila"
right there in the background.
It was a couple of years
after "Jamila" came out.
Just a neat, neat
picture that I found
in the archives in Bishkek.
So then Altay fearful that
Soviet spies would try
to assassinate him for his
radio work, Altay immigrated
to the U.S. and he was one of
the first Kyrgyz ever to do so.
He settled in New York
City as Kadyr knows,
in Flushing Meadows, right?
A melting pot of nationalities
and Cold War intrigues.
And he started a
20-year career working
in the New York public libraries
-- a New York public library
and Columbia University Library.
I think Altay would feel very at
home at the Library of Congress.
I am sure he was
here many times.
So now it gets neat.
You have these two parallel
stories of men living
and what was fascinating
to me is when I decided
to incorporate Altay into the
story, which is a couple years
after I had started
research Aitmatov's life,
I found out the way
their lives intersected.
So far from home, cut off
from his family and culture,
Altay suffered immensely.
He was a persona non grata
having been declared a traitor
after jumping lines and
sentenced to 25 years
in jail should he ever
return to the Soviet Union.
His name was blackened
by propaganda campaigns
in Soviet Kyrgyzia.
His solace was music
of his homeland.
Lilting melodies played on the
Kyrgyz three-string guitar,
the komuz and Aitmatov's
stories, which formed part
of his collection of 5,000,
6,000 books on Central Asia
in his personal library
in Queens New York.
So about that meeting
in 1975, in the 1970s
when the two men's lives
intersected for the first time.
Now this is the Cold War.
Alta is persona non grata
in the Soviet Union.
The KGB is alive and
strong and here's a picture
of these two men meeting
in Altay's apartment
in Queen's New York.
So that's the American
angle to the book.
During a period of warming
and U.S. Soviet relations
in the 1970s when
Space cooperation
between the countries started
and cultural exchanges
took place,
we all call that detente,
we called it detente.
Aitmatov got invited to the
U.S. for the performance
of a play he had
written about Stalinism
and the scars it had left
on the Kyrgyz people.
As a big fan of Aitmatov's
works,
Altay played an instrumental
role in Aitmatov getting invited
by the U.S. State Department.
He was very helpful
in getting the visa.
The two men met in
Aitmatov's New York hotel room
on the very day that Soviet and
American astronauts shook hands
in space during the
Apollo-Soyuz hookup.
You can't make that stuff up.
And I just want to read
a passage from the book.
The scene was an uncanny
terrestrial version
of the nomadic events that had
happened earlier in the day.
At noon New York time Apollo
had achieved a firm linkup
with Soyuz over the
Atlantic Ocean 620 miles west
of Portugal.
In a culmination of
three years of joint work
by the Cold War rivals.
Soviet cosmonaut Alexey Leonov
welcomed American astronaut Tom
Stafford through the hatches
with a hearty handshake.
President Ford and General
Secretary Brezhnev sent
congratulating messages
to the crews.
It Aitmatov's hotel
that evening,
620 miles lower a celebratory
atmosphere prevailed
but of a far different nature.
The impromptu gathering
of Kyrgyz in New York,
though unpublicized had
as much significance
for the Kyrgyz people as did
the Apollo-Soyuz handshake,
maybe even more.
It represented a coming together
of the disparate parts
of the Kyrgyz elite.
Two leading cultural lights of
Soviet Kyrgyzia in the same room
with the founding voice
of the Kyrgyz service
of American's Radio Liberty.
A Kyrgyz Hall of
Fame, if you will.
What unified then was blood,
and the simple joy of connection
that stood as an affirmation
that the Kyrgyz people
were living, existing,
and staying together, even
across ideological divides
that seemed insurmountable
to so many --
the day's events
not withstanding.
In 1979, Altay returned
to Radio Liberty in Munich
and headed the Kyrgyz service.
He arrived in time to
chronicle the demise
of his archenemy
the Soviet Union.
As the Soviet Union stumbled
into Afghanistan in the 1980s,
Aitmatov's pros got stronger.
Aitmatov was widely
published in the USSR
and around the world
in 160 languages.
But his public statements
often sang the praises
of the Soviet system.
That was the price of Aitmatov's
inner freedom to write his mind,
to write his conscience.
Freedom inside had
to be purchased
with compromise from
the outside.
With the advent of perestroika
the two men, Azamat Altay
and Chingiz Aitmatov
met more frequently
with Aitmatov brushing
aside the increasingly KGB.
Aitmatov was appointed a member
of Gorbachev's reform team
and spoke openly about failures
of the Soviet system during
perestroika and the importance
of restoring the place
of language, history,
and culture for the Kyrgyz
and other constituent
Republics of the USSR.
This photo, likely from 1989
shows a relaxed gathering
in Munich, Kyrgyz
style, with Aitmatov,
the honored guest getting
the head of the lamb.
Altay, the oldest at the table
is seated to Aitmatov's left.
But one meeting in particular
symbolized the new era.
A time of hope and
ultimately redemption .
Aitmatov was in Munich
presenting his latest book.
Unbeknownst to him, Altay
and other Kyrgyz working
at Radio Liberty
were in the audience.
The KGB in an effort
to avoid a meeting
between the two men hustled
Aitmatov and his wife Maria
out of the hall and
into a waiting car.
A James Bond like
car chase ensued.
So this is from the book.
When the car carrying
the Aimatov's arrived
at their hotel a white van
pulled up right behind.
Outstepped Azamat Altay
with several Kyrgyz
adults and children.
The wary KGB agent rushed
to block their approach
but Aitmatov halted them.
"These are my people.
Let me speak with them."
He said.
Aitmatov's simple
gesture spoke volumes.
It said, "That's enough."
Excuse me.
And with his command to
the two KGB officers fear
and silence engrained in the
Kyrgyz people for decades
and carried by Aitmatov
himself started to recede.
It was as if Aitmatov were
saying it was time to learn how
to live in a normal society.
No more keeping silent, no more
fear, and no more tragedies.
Yes, the fatherless
Aitmatov seemed to be saying,
"Let the next generation
of Kyrgyz grow
up with their fathers and
let the KGB learn another way
to carry out its work.
So this is a fun picture.
Altay returned to Kyrgyzstan in
1995 after a 55-year absence.
His criminal sentence was
abolished and he was greeted
like a hero in independent
Kyrgyzstan.
When he stepped off the plane
onto the tarmac he
kissed the ground.
There to meet him
was Chingiz Aitmatov.
So you can see here Altay
is under the orange arrow,
Chingiz Aitmatov
is under the blue,
and under the green is
Chingiz Aitmatov's son, Askar,
who is a Kyrgyz diplomat
in New York at the time,
and Askar got Azamat
Altay the visa
and Askar accompanied Azamat
Altay all the way back
to Kyrgyzstan at a time
when there weren't --
you had to go through Tashkent
and wait hours, hours,
and hours.
So it's really kind of neat
that the Aitmatov's were
on both sides taking
care of Altay.
So what are the lessons
from their lives?
The individual accounts.
Freedom of thought, speech, and
religion are the foundations
of a democratic society.
And take nothing for granted.
Nothing is guaranteed.
Dedicate yourself to what you
believe in, structure your life
to achieve it, base
decisions upon it and yes,
be ready to make compromises
to achieve the larger goal,
and in the case of Azamat Altay,
be ready to lose precious
things along the way.
"The moral arc of history
bends towards justice."
Martin Luther King said.
Both men, Azamat Altay and
Chingiz Aitmatov found justice
in their lifetimes and that's
the redemption in the title.
So Altay's redemption we could
see was returning to Kyrgyzstan
and as we saw in that wonderful
film, being greeted like a hero
by his fellow countrymen
and women.
A few years earlier Aitmatov
himself before Altay's return,
Altay himself after decades
of looking found his father,
Torekul Aitmatov was at
the bottom of a grave
with 137 other skeletons
piled on top,
all victims of Stalin's purges.
Dry conditions in
the mass grave,
which had been a brick kiln,
had preserved the written order
sentencing Torekul Aitmatov,
his father, Chingiz's, to death.
The excavation of the mass
grave captivated Soviet Kyrgyzia
during the Summer of 1991.
And I'm going to show you a
little bit of a video here.
So this is a video that
was taken by the people
who were excavating
the grave and pulling
out these skulls, 137.
Pulling out personal
objects that were preserved
in the climate, this
warm climate.
These are shoes.
This is the brick kiln that
became the burial ground.
Here are other artifacts.
This all happened
in July of 1991,
six months before the
collapse of the Soviet Union.
So here you can see in his
kalpak the worker is digging.
And here they're
pulling out the letters.
These are the sentencing
documents that preserved
that had the names of the
people who were executed
and then they were able to
match the bodies to the people
and they were able
to tell relatives
who had waited 53 years that
they had found the remains
of their fathers,
brothers, husbands.
So that gives you a sense.
Aitmatov himself gave
voice to the miracle --
so this is from the book --
this is a quote e from
Chingiz Aitmatov --
"Everything disappeared,
disintegrated,
the bodies of the unfortunate
people, their shoes, clothes,"
Aitmatov would say a few weeks
later, "except this paper,
this document from
that era, with the name
of Torekul Aitmatov, which
remained intact enough to read."
Dry conditions had
preserved the documents,
but the Aitmatov family know
that something else was at work
in solving the gruesome mystery.
And so did many other Kyrgyz.
"There is in the world
some higher justice.
some higher justice,
timeless, and absolute."
Aitmatov said, "something maybe
beyond our everyday existence."
Loss, redemption, and
hope, a true story
of the Cold War from
Central Asia.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: Thank you so much
for such a brilliant
presentation.
We have all been so
inspired by all of this.
We do have time for
a couple of questions
so if someone has a
question please go ahead.
>> I didn't ask of this, Jeff,
but how did you come to decide
to write about [inaudible],
both of them on one book.
They have own books and stories.
It was very [inaudible]
managed to tell the stories
of two great men in one book.
>> Jeffrey Lilley: I initially
wanted to write a biography
of Aitmatov because I really
liked his writing and I thought
that this is writer
that actually Americans
should know about.
So that was the original idea
and I didn't find any biography
of Aitmatov in English.
And so that's what I started
out for three years doing
and then I was interviewing
[inaudible] from Radio Liberty
and he -- I was interviewing
him about Aitmatov
and he mentioned Altay.
And I had never known -- I had
never heard of Altay's name.
The whole time I was in
Kyrgyzstan for three years,
and he told me all about him and
I just thought wow, you know,
that's a pretty interesting
story too and he was outside,
Aitmatov was inside, and I
didn't know what I would find
but I just -- it would
be more interesting --
it was just a more interesting
story to me at that point.
And as you as a formal
journalist,
you know good stories are
important and weaving it.
So I just then decided
to weave them,
and then as I said the
other day, I think a writer,
you have to be lucky too.
And I was lucky because
I didn't know
that they had met
in New York in 1975.
I mean I think [inaudible]
said that,
but then I found a letter
courtesy of [inaudible]
that Altay wrote to a friend
after he had just met Aitmatov
and he realized what
an important meeting
that was for him.
The photos were there and
then people were still alive,
you know, and I could
get the story.
Yes Mary-Jane?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Jeffrey Lilley: Yes, well
I'll tell you, as was mentioned
in the film, Aitmatov lost a lot
of cousins and family members --
three uncles, and I
can't even remember,
and his father to the purges.
Of his own family,
there were four kids,
Chingiz was the oldest
and Ilgez was second,
and Ilgez was a scientist, a
geologist, he's still alive.
He was head of the
Academy of Sciences.
He was -- you know, worked
in the geological
mining industry I think,
I'm not quite sure,
but he is about 80 --
he must be 87 or something now.
Because Chingiz would be 90,
so he's two years younger,
88, distinguished man.
And then Roza is alive
and well in Bishkek
and she was the youngest.
And she was nine months old
when her father disappeared.
Never knew her father.
She's written a bunch
of good books,
which have been very helpful,
about the family history.
So she's alive and
well and was very --
she was trained as a teacher
and very active in NGO work
for many years after
independence.
And then, actually
Roza is youngest.
Luzia was the third and Luzia
went to the Technical Institute
and got a degree -- I can't
remember, in engineering.
She died relatively young.
I think in the mid '70s.
But she was born as a twin.
And there was a boy and a girl.
Luzia was born and the boys name
was Revo [assumed spelling],
so when you put it
together it's a Revo-Luzia,
which shows you how
their parents
where such committed
Communist to the cause.
And yet the father gets
purged, you know, it's insanity.
So she passed away but she
has a son, a couple of kids,
and he is a writer and he has
written some interesting works
about legacy of his uncle.
Roza remained, Ilgez
remained, yes, and yeah.
That's right.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Jeffrey Lilley: Right, I
mean, I think -- I don't know.
I probably did 30, 40
interviews around the world --
Europe, US., Kyrgyzstan.
In terms of feedback, good
feedback, I was very gratified
to get an email the other
day from the former president
of Norton Publishing and
the former chairman emeritus
of the Yale University Press,
one man, who was very helpful
to me during the attempt
to find a publisher
because I didn't write this
book having a publisher saying,
"Jeff, we're going to
publish this book."
So it was, I was I had to go out
and market it and as they say,
you only need one person to
say yes, but a lot do say no.
So his name is -- well,
it's not important --
but he said something to
the effect of "History told
at its best, narratives, scope,
pace" and that was
really gratifying.
I think, yeah, the other
people I've talked to --
I haven't been back to the
states since it was published,
I just got back four days ago,
have found it to be a good read,
a page turner, you know, yeah
and educating them about a part
of the world they may not
have known much about.
But I think the thing
that I hope connects is
that these are two
human individuals
and it's actually
a universal story
that transcends geography
or state borders.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Jeffrey Lilley:
Yes, you know,
I think I was pretty lucky --
no I was very lucky and I
think that's a testament
to Kyrgyzstan being open.
You know, I had researchers
on the ground because I wasn't
in Kyrgyzstan for a lot of
the time and they were able
to get everything, you
know, that we needed.
But I made requests here
as well, FOIA requests,
and you know, our bureaucracy
is slow but, you know,
eventually I got a response,
so actually the research
was pretty darn good,
pretty darn good, and I
felt lucky about that.
Yeah.
>> Joan Weeks: Thank
you very much.
Gather a round of applause.
>> Jeffrey Lilley: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.